oggi vi parlerò della di specialista
l'anti specialista sono io io sono
potrei definirmi un artista nel mio
lavoro quotidiano utilizzo linguaggi
molto diversi e scelto di non
specializzarmi veramente nessuno di
questi è particolare per me essere qui
oggi perché questo evento è organizzato
da un'università da studenti e
l'università e per me personalmente un
posto dove i sogni vengono imbottigliati
in un prodotto vendibile con etichetta
ma permetterà in altre parole
l'università è un posto che scegliamo di
frequentare se vogliamo specializzarsi
in qualcosa o qualcosa di nostra scelta
e oggi vorrei parlarvi di questa scelta
questa scelta che tutti facciamo e
quindi riflettendo su questo ho deciso
di raccontarvi delle storie la prima
storia non è nulla di nuovo ma è una
storia che tutti conosciamo perché tutti
lo abbiamo vissuto sulla nostra pelle e
inizia più o meno così eravamo piccoli
piccoli ed eravamo molto nuovi su questo
pianeta
eravamo appena arrivati e ne stavamo
ancora scoprendo con grande entusiasmo
le luci le ombre nelle superfici mamma
nonna una formica mammona formica una
formica si seguirà
poi un giorno ci venne chiesto che cosa
vuoi fare da grande beh ognuno di noi
quel giorno scoprì due cose che sarebbe
diventato grande e che gli sarebbe
toccato a fare qualcosa nella vita
ora se noi avessimo avuto la prontezza
all'epoca di rispondere mamma scusa
sto contando le formiche e invece no no
i bambini adorano questo tipo di domande
è solo un'altra occasione per fargli
esplodere i neuroni e allora escono
fuori cose bellissime di questo tipo
questo qui sto citando due bambini che
conosco frido cosa vuoi fare da grande
il pilota sono un po lente le slide
scusate e tu rocco l'elefante
ora per fortuna i nostri bambini non
hanno la minima idea di che cosa sia il
mondo professionale adulto perché noi
quando facciamo ad un bambino la domanda
che cosa vuoi fare da grande non li
stiamo chiedendo che cosa vuole fare da
grande e gli stiamo chiedendo che lavoro
vuoi fare da grande che professione per
svolgere da grande io se io chiedessi
mio figlio samuel che cos'è il lavoro
lui mi risponderebbe se potesse sono
quasi sicura che mi risponderebbe così
mamma
il lavoro è quella cosa che tagliate il
tempo di stare con me e bene e andiamo
avanti perché la storia va avanti
effettivamente cresciamo effettivamente
scopriamo che diventiamo grandi e
diventiamo grandi molto velocemente a
volte più veloci di quanto si voglia e
raggiungiamo un memo un momento della
nostra vita in cui passiamo dall'essere
bambini all'essere ragazzi questo
momento viene definito povertà e del
momento in cui la maggior parte di noi
altri sprofonda nella barbarie più
putrida ora forse voi che a roma siete
un pochino più civili di noi ma io vengo
dall alta tuscia una zona molto molto un
paesino di 5 mila abitanti alle scuole
medie da me si tiravano astucci da una
parte all'altra della stanza si
rovesciavano banchi si rovesciavano
professori giuro l'ho visto si parla di
si comincia a parlare di sesso si
comincia a parlare di droga si comincia
a fumare si cominciò a mancare di
rispetto nella maniera più svergognate
deliberata si comincia a esplorare anzi
l'unico concetto che si ha intenzione di
esplorare a quell'età è il concetto di
figo e non figo questa fico
questo non è figo bene quello che
succede in questa e in questo periodo in
cui i nostri bambini ragazzi non
sappiamo bene che cosa sono e che
estremamente difficile avere a che fare
con loro per cui succede avviene da
parte del del mondo adulto quella che io
chiamo un certo tipo di selezione
innaturale molto poco corretta nei
confronti i nostri giovani
suona più o meno così non urlerò il
microfono mi prometto sei un fannullone
non te ne farai mai niente della tua
vita
smettere di sognare adesso smetto di
sognare
pochi perché effettivamente anche i
nostri sogni crescono con noi
cioè noi non siamo un palloncino che si
ingrandisce con il tempo anche il nostro
contenuto no il nostro contenuto emotivo
si ingrandisce con noi e che cosa
succede succede che un certo punto
questi sogni diventano grandi e grandi e
grandi e perdiamo un po al controllo
continuano a crescere e ci pieghiamo
sotto il peso dei nostri sogni e ci
sentiamo dei fessi ci sentiamo dei fessi
perché ci guardiamo intorno e tutto il
resto del mondo cammina spigliato io ho
da fare tre minuti prendo il treno se
perde il treno devo aspettare altri 5
minuti
noi siamo lì chini sotto il peso dei
nostri sogni perché i nostri sogni
pesano pesano perché ci rendiamo conto
che la realtà intorno a noi non ha le
risorse per mantenerne e le dimensioni
nessuno ci darà una mano a tenere il
peso dei nostri sogni per cui facciamo
la decisione spesso spesso facciamo la
decisione molto facile ora devo prendere
il treno scusate ci andiamo avanti
perché la storia va avanti
siamo alla fine più o meno alla fine
delle scuole superiori e penso che la
maggior parte delle persone presenti si
ricordano un po come ci si sente no la
maggior parte cioè siamo siamo belli
siamo brutti
siamo felici siamo depressi siamo tutto
insieme e la maggior parte di noi altri
non vuol pensare ad altro che ad altro
sesso o allo stesso sesso ma il sesso
basta che in fondo è lo stesso è un
giorno ci venne chiesto che cosa vuoi
fare adesso
ciao ma sto chiedendo una cosa che cosa
vuoi fare adesso
adesso sei grande io sono grande siamo
diventati grandi apparentemente un certo
punto siamo diventati grandi non ci
siamo accorti veramente di quanto è
successo e adesso l'aspettativa del
mondo intero ci crolla sulle spalle e
dobbiamo affrettarci trovare una
risposta che cosa vai a fare cosa voglio
fare cosa voglio fare io voglio studiare
ingegneria bravo
ora il problema che io vedo è che la
risposta vera non è veramente prese in
considerazione cioè lo ripeto quando ci
viene chiesta la domanda che cosa vuoi
fare da grande e che il lavoro vuoi fare
ci viene presentata una lista di
risposte tra le quali scegliere ed orali
6 risposte anche molto molto lunga noi
che ci dà l'illusione che siano
tantissime possibilità in verità le
possibilità sono ancora di più però
quello che non è incluso nella lista
molto spesso non è perché no ma che idea
no e io vi posso elencare una serie di
risposte sbagliate per esempio è una è
questa io da grande vorrei fare il
musicista oppure io non avere un'altra
io non so molteplici interessi io mi
appassionati di astronomia
ho una grande amore per la letteratura e
mi affascina il teatro o quante ne vuoi
ma di una terza risposta che secondo me
quella che ognuno di noi temo un pochino
che è questa io
non lo so non lo sai ma ci siamo accorti
di quanto la risposta non lo so ci
spaventi questa è una società che non
accetta la possibilità che si possa non
sapere qualcosa e questo lo sanno i
nostri bambini
i nostri bambini crescono con il terrore
di non sapere abbastanza ora terrore
forse una parola un po esagerata ma io
mi ricordo essere bambina e inventarmi
le balle più assurde pur di non
ammettere che non sapevo la risposta
esatta
anzi vi è un esempio classico che quello
lì tipo fine fine elementare inizio
scuole medie in cui viene chiesto la
capitale della turchia
io lo so ma non me lo ricordo le balle
più assurde pur di non ammette di non
sapere qualcosa e io ero una di quelle
bambine che voleva sapere tutto era
un'ossessione cioè io non è che non
cercate di convincermi che io mi
convince o di sapere tutto no io avevo
tutto sapevo tutto ed ero così pronta a
rispondere alla domanda che cosa vuoi
fare da grande e beatrice aiuta grande
voglio andare a new york e fare
l'illustratrice bene quella era la mia
risposta agli 8 anni ai 12 anni ai 16
anni c'è poi comincia a essere sospetto
la cosa ai 19 anni e lo volevo tanto era
un ambizione così bruciante che ai 20
anni ottiene una borsa di studio di
svariate decine di migliaia di dollari
per andare a studiare in una delle
università più famose per
l'illustrazione che ci sia mi si stava
avverando l'ambizione di una vita no
allora presi l'aereo e due giorni dopo
essere arrivata a new york mi innamorai
sono catastrofi nove mesi dopo aspettava
un bambino
la cosa più interessante è che ero
veramente felice felice come non darò
mai stata
prima mai stata prima non sapevo nemmeno
che cosa come definirla questa cosa e
abbandonare la borsa di studio
abbandonare la scuola e abbandonare una
città in cui non ero felice
ora mi senti come se avessi saltato da
un treno in corsa e mi senti come se si
è scoperto che effettivamente ater
l'atterraggio non è poi tanto duro
no ma due anni e mezzo dopo ogni mezzo
dopo di vita di vita non facile perché
nessuno ha mai detto che la vita deve
essere facile come nessuno ha mai detto
che la vita la via più facile sia quella
giusta non e mezzo dopo ricevetti una
lettera dalla persona che io stimo molto
una grande e illustratrice e mi scrisse
beatrice col cuore in mano
beatrice se non studi ti ci vorrà una
montagna di tempo a diventare una
grandissima artista
ora io volli riflette su quel
significato di tempo se io dovessi
impiegare 200 anni di impegno a capire
che cos'è l'arte sarà valsa la pena
se io dopo 200 anni ancora non avrò
capito che cos'è l'arte ma avrò messo
impegno e passione in quella cosa sarà
valsa la pena comunque perché la mia
vita perché il mio tempo perché la
vostra vita e al vostro tempo
allora vorrei parlare del tempo vorrei
parlare del modo in cui questo mondo in
cui viviamo ha bisogno del nostro tempo
ha bisogno che noi sacrifichiamo del
tempo e vorrei parlarne ora le stesse
rimasto un pochino fisserà un po di
tempo ma vorrei parlare attraverso le
slide
ora questo prenderà un po di tempo
perché il mio sono molto lente e devo
andare quasi alla fine ma andrò avanti
scusate non sai di cosa che non vi ho
mostrato perché ho deciso di andare
avanti avanti avanti
vabbè muove lo dico era era una metafora
per descrivere i nostri sogni che si
ingrandiscono eccoci bene per spiegare a
me stessa il significato del tempo in
questo mondo voglio creare un grafico
poi effettivamente non riuscì a fare un
grafico perché non sono brava a fare i
grafici allora feci una serie di
vignette e questa è la leggenda per
capire le vignette vediamo un sacco di
denaro
i nostri anni di vita in una busta e un
certificato ora questi siamo noi siamo
noi di fronte al nostro direttore
universitario pieni di speranze offriamo
cinque anni della nostra vita del denaro
in cambio di un certificato poi andiamo
avanti
questi siamo noi abbiamo trovato un
lavoro
ora offriamo 40 anni della nostra vita è
un certificato in cambio di denaro
ora questi siamo noi siamo noi con i
nervi a pezzi le spalle rotte scusate il
pessimismo e offriamo sei decenni della
nostra vita e quattro decenni di
contributi pagati in cambio di una
pensione
ragazzi questa è lieto fine che per me
sono un po come ok lei resta arrivato
alla fine dei suoi giorni si goda
l'ultimo tempo santa pace non le
romperemo più le scatole ma io che ogni
tanto gioco fai la pessimista ho pensato
a un altro finale
che ci dice come sarà il mondo tra 40
anni
chi ci dice come sarà il mondo tra 65
quattro decenni come sarà il concetto di
lavoro in tutto quel tempo per me queste
sono domande molto molto importanti
perché forse perché ho ancora 24 anni
forse perché un bambino di due anni e
mezzo ma io me lo chiedo spesso e mi
chiedo spesso il valore delle nostre
scelte
ora non ho parlato di intuizione maiora
ora menzionerò la parola intuizione
perché ovviamente la nostra intuizione
che ci porta poi a fare delle scelte
ora ho ancora due minuti di tempo prima
di andare a svenire nell'altra stanza vi
dedico una storia anzi la dedico a
chiunque si sia sentito almeno una volta
nella vita in dovere di compiere una
scelta che non gli apparteneva
vi è un treno lunghissimo che metteva
pure dorati e corre a velocità infernali
ragazzo che stai per salire sul treno 6
de dubbi aspetto ragazzo che si è salito
sul treno e senti che il tuo posto non è
lì scendi scendi scendi scendi come
salta salta dal tetto del treno e
scoprirai che non fa poi tanto male e
nel momento in cui aprì gli occhi e ti
accorgi che puoi camminare alzati alzati
e vedi che i lividi passano i dolori
scompaiono ha esaltato sei sceso dal
treno e finalmente capito che il tuo
posto nel mondo e qui semplicemente qui
attorno a te
altre persone perché sono stati in tanti
a saltar giù dal treno prima di te
benvenuto